my goal is to how many of you in the
audience are geniuses already I think
that's true but my goal is to turn you
into a behavior change genius I'm gonna
pick one little slice of it it's
different than what Sheena will be
talking about later and they're they're
very complementary approaches I can get
the visual up on the screen here and if
not I will just kind of keep going today
I'm going to talk about habit and what I
want us to do first of all is everyone
you've got your mobile phone right can
everybody pull that out and turn your
ringer on yeah first ever told you to do
that right and turn it out turn the
ringer on here's what we're gonna do
every time you hear somebody's phone
ring I want you to do this
I'm not tenth and you know relax
okay so just a very quick relaxation
exercise so when you hear a phone ring
ring means relax now if it's your phone
going off yeah let it ring once or twice
but didn't turn it off we don't have to
hear the whole Lady Gaga mean tongue
have you okay we got that okay so habits
habits habits the class I'm teaching
right now here at Stanford is about
using technology to create habits of
calming a stress reduction and I think
habits are very important if we only
have information and we don't I miss
that one talk about that if we don't
change our behavior information frankly
doesn't matter in fact rarely does
information lead to behavior change
there are some cases where it does but
just because somebody gives me a stat
about you know I'm out of shape doesn't
mean I'm gonna go and start exercising
right away and we all know that's the
case and so the challenge is how do you
change people's lives by changing their
habits and that's been an obsession of
mine for about 18 months in the health
arena I came here 93 to study this
question how to use computers to change
people's attitudes and behaviors really
wasn't a health person although I'm
always been a helped enthusiast but in
the last two years I've been sucked into
this arena because of the changes we
need to make a lot of them have to do
with health I don't have the exact
number of how much we can save money by
changing behaviors somebody had a
previous event I was that said 80% 80%
of the I don't know what the number is I
do believe that by using systematic
methods to think about behavior change
that we can solve bigger problems and to
this point I'm gonna offend some people
sorry I'm but I just have to at this
point people have been fairly sloppy
thinkers about behavior change okay so
don't so listen to things with a
critical ear look at things with the
critical eye including what I'm going to
be showing you today there's a Facebook
class idea here I was on the New York
Times somebody asked me to talk just
briefly about this I won't go in too
deeply but in 10 weeks they got millions
of people involved the New York Times
did do a cover story three years later
came out Sunday the derivative stories
of that weren't always accurate
don't trust everything you read but the
New York Times story was mostly on
target but it's about this the class was
all about how can we systematically have
impact with these apps and how can you
do that in my labs work here at Stanford
we've been systematically looking at
change behavior change
now the metaphor and the metaphor breaks
down pretty fast but imagine if you were
a chemist a pharmacist you know somebody
even in construction and you didn't have
the periodic table of elements to work
with imagine what a problem that would
be to date we have not had a periodic
table of behavior change types and I
recognize this a while ago I try to get
some students in Europe to do it they
didn't really pick it up so I said okay
we're gonna do this and my lab and I
have been through a few iterations of
this we call it the behavior grid we've
passed out a product from my lab you've
got a little card pull that out right
now for some of you will have to get out
your microscopes or magnifying glasses
and look at the side of the card that
has that grid I'm gonna give you a brief
intro to that in the hopes that you will
then study it further
in the hopes that when you think about a
behavior change type you'll be able to
put it in the right place in the grid
the big idea here is there's 15 types of
behavior each one has a different recipe
strategies that works so if you're
trying to get a greendot behavior done
solving with black path strategies
that's like trying to cook a birthday
cake with chili powder right you've got
to use the right ingredients for the
right target you've got green behaviors
look at the first column we decided comb
green we could have called them new
these are behaviors that are new to
people about a year ago I got an email
here from the editor of Playboy and he
said hey BJ we're putting together a
cool professors list we want you to be
in in in Playboy we're gonna come
Stamford and you know talk to you take
some shots and that is high good so I'd
never been in Playboy before and so see
for me that's a green behavior it's
characterized by fear uncertain what
would happen if I said yes what would
happen is so well I didn't end up saying
no but as you look at the behavior types
we're trying to get people to do if it's
new they're gonna have fear and
uncertainty around it and they there may
be lack of ability they've never done it
before
mint calm good example of how they
address this notice all the things they
do I've circled in orange to address the
issues of fear and security now I'm
going to use some examples from the
consumer internet space because in many
ways they are leading the pack in turn
change in people's behaviors and by
adopting the tech techniques they use we
can do a lot better job in the health
space let's go to blue behaviors the
next column blue is characterized by
things you've done before Virgin
Airlines they fly in virgin a lot it's
no big deal for me to book a ticket fly
in virgin there's nothing uncertain
about that there's no barrier there and
so when it comes to blue behaviors it's
helping people do what they already know
how to do whether it's buying a book on
Amazon showing up to class on time you
know using email using Google Docs
what-have-you
now I'm not going to go through all of
this but then we have a class called
purple behaviors
these are all about doing stuff and then
the grand black behaviors are about
doing less or stop doing stuff so even
in those five columns actually what I'd
like you to do is if you have a pin
where that orange line is draw a line
down through those columns so you see
really clearly here the do stuff side
and here's the do less or do stop doing
side of the grid now that you have your
pin out also blue path this is my
favorite so in the chart circle that
this is where habits live and blue path
means doing something you know how to do
for the rest of your life need a book go
to Amazon my alarm rings I wake up or I
turn off the alarm I go to the fridge
you know I walk out to the kitchen I get
some water what do you do all the time
without making decisions so understand
some behaviors to require decisions and
some don't fact in some ways that is a
measure of a strength of a habit is how
much do you do it without making a
decision for better or for worse the
winning technology companies and this
isn't a perfect list I grabbed it from
TechCrunch last fall but it's a pretty
good list they're good at creating
habits so they're very good at getting
people to this spot now you don't just
start here at least from our perspective
there's a path there's a route to get
people to that blue path certainly they
have to use your service the first time
then they have to do it again
maybe there's a period of time where
they're using at 30-day trial
and that eventually you hope they're
always using whatever product program
service you're providing and so on so in
some ways it's a little bit at least now
with the words you can say green dot
blue dot and then eventually we want to
get people into a blue path or do we
want to do purple path that's do more of
something exercise more eat more
vegetables and so on from now on do you
really want to do a path or you want to
do a span a span is for a limited period
of time 14 days 21 days six weeks what
have you or path we want you to buy in
for the rest of your life spans are
easier to do than pass the winners are
really good at
these habits watch how they do it if
you're not using the popular
technologies you should be using them
there's a reason
Twitter Facebook Cora Groupon there's a
reason those people are winning and you
can extract the psychological recipe
from those things and use it in your
work related to changing health
behaviors that's a big big big part of
what we're doing in my Stanford lab what
are the recipes that work focus on those
behaviors imitate the winning formulas
don't study the losers it's a waste of
time
so deeper on habits I think there are
three steps to new habits and unless
you've read my stuff you've not heard
these before you have some stuff coming
out there's some post-its coming out
right now so when you get a post-it pass
it along grab a post-it pass along will
use that in a minute the first step is
to make it tiny so let's say you want a
member of your organization let's say
you want your work force you want people
to exercise some more they're not
exercising if you go out and say hey
we're all going to create a habit of
exercising 30 minutes every day you all
know what will happen it's not very very
few people will actually make that a
habit we've seen that over and over that
these big leaps don't work what does
work is make it really small such as
walk five minutes a day find a spot
where it lives in somebody's routine
right after you take your coffee break
right after you come back from lunch and
then you train the cycle in other words
you don't work on getting people to walk
30 minutes a day until they have that
automatic reaction oh I'm back from my
coffee break I'm gonna go walk for five
minutes so they're not making a decision
about exercise they are just
automatically doing it and that's it I
think those are all the steps so I call
this tiny habits here are the steps here
and here is the assertion we've not yet
shown scientifically but I think it's
true plant a tiny habit in the right
spot and it won't grow without coaxing
so the right little behavior once you
get it trained in cycle let's say it's
walk five minutes
you don't have to further push people to
exercise more if the context is right
they will naturally expand to the full
behavior what I want to do is together
right now let's work through a case
study I've never done this before but
let's try this okay I'm gonna have you
vote on something and it might be
sensitive so I'm gonna have you close
your eyes and don't look at how other
people voting got it okay ready it'd
only be like 12 seconds ready close your
eyes how many people wished you had a
better flossing habit raise your hand
okay go ahead and put your hands down
hopefully nobody peeked but I will tell
you it was at least 60% let's take this
bit more than I thought actually let's
take this and apply it to flossing make
it tiny floss one tooth find the right
spot find the right spot right after you
brush and then just train the cycle in
other words don't floss all your teeth
unless you really really want to what
you're focusing on is just right after I
brush I floss you already know how to
floss all your teeth right that's not
what you need to drill on what you need
to drill on is the automatic I brush and
then I floss and the other piece that I
didn't put here is once you've lost that
one tooth what you need to do somehow
this is what I did it's like victory
I did it you know don't floss the rest
of your teeth unless you really want to
as soon as it gets painful like how this
is a drag I think your brain said nope
I'm not making this a habit so it has to
be something that you're like yeah I get
a floss this one tooth oh and guess if I
do them all awesome I mean awesome er
okay so on the post-it that I handed to
you what I want you to do on that post
is write floss one tooth got it okay
we'll come back to that here we go
floss one tooth now what happens I
believe and again we're working showing
this scientifically is once you get that
little habit going guess what every day
I floss one tooth in fact I've lost
twice a day because my habit is after I
brush I floss
does not matter when I brush I floss so
it's twice a day you can expand it to a
larger behavior walk 5 minutes walk 30
eat 2 vegetables eat 5 floss one tooth
floss all your teeth that expansion from
blue to purple is much much easier than
going for green dot you know for the
first time ever do something and this is
where as you look at the companies that
have won they're very good at this get a
teeny habit going use us for search use
us for music appreciation use us to
share photos and they take that and they
expanded into other domains until you're
using Google Docs and Google Maps and
did it it so understand that dynamic you
get a little thing working and expand it
we haven't heard any phone rings how
ring let's practice Wow either we're not
very popular or people know we're in a
meeting let's talk about the phone in
terms of understanding behavior how
behavior works all the 15 behaviors work
this way let me use this example imagine
that your phone rings and you don't
answer it think of a few reasons why
that's happened to you right ok ready go
take 10 seconds
okay how many people thought of well I
didn't answer it because I didn't hear
it it was in the car and I was in the
house how many people had an answer
something like that okay so that's the
trigger which is the ring never arrived
the trigger is the call to action it's
like do it now
phone rings I can pick it up the signal
turns green oh I can go now how many
people thought of oh wow
here's a person calling I'm in a bad
mood I don't want to talk to them I
don't know who okay so if that's you
raise your left hand okay just hold your
left hand up oh I don't really want to
talk right now my bad okay keep the hand
up how many of you put something down
like I'm in a meeting I'm in the shower
I'm driving I'm sewing okay boom we made
it you can put your hands down okay
so right there I wished I had known this
back in 1993 when I came here to do this
work there's only three elements that
must happen at the same moment for
behavior to occur and this is what they
are motivation there's to be some level
ability and there has to be a trigger
and those things have to happen at the
same moment if anyone's missing the
behavior won't happen let's and there's
a there's a threshold of sorts that if
you're above the threshold and the
trigger hits the behavior will occur if
you're below it it won't let me show you
some examples here's something I stand
for development office called Genesis
hey guess what donate a million dollars
okay hard to do but they say man if you
donate a million dollars we'll give you
a special box seats here at the stadium
will name a building in your honor
dennah de they're gonna keep boosting
the motivation but notice how here in
the model if they keep going it never
goes over the line because for most
people donating a million dollars is
really really hard
can I have well should I do this yeah
well I've never done this before okay
now I want to take the time so let's say
the target behavior like the photo was
to sit in this position and go like this
and just hold it there for 10 seconds
okay now I could pull out money and say
okay here's $100 to do it here's more
and if you
you can't do it it doesn't matter how
high the motivations now there's lots of
things I can't do that happens to be
easy for me but the point is you need to
if it's hard to do don't boost the
motivation make it easier to do and from
a behavior design perspective working
with my students this is the natural
reaction if we're triggering the
behavior and it's not working we're
going to make it easier to do before we
mess with motivation motivations the
last of the three things you manipulate
here's the part of the chart I like the
best easy to do doesn't matter where the
motivation is and let me show you a
video that typifies this this is my dog
Millie what she wants me to do is kick
the ball so she can chase it now notice
how that worked
but okay next she puts it in the very
center of the house you can't go
anywhere without going here so even
without looking you'll walk through and
kick the ball okay so she makes it super
easy so the point here is here's where
Millie's at she wants me to kick the
ball
she knows my motivations often low cuz
I've done this thousands and thousands
of times so it's gotta be easy to do and
now she's even better fact she puts it
outside the showers so as I step out I
kick it she's and then she runs over
into the like the bedroom she knows and
she just puts it in all the right spots
how can we do this well when we're
designing for health systems now notice
the more you do something and this isn't
a great example let's take the walk five
minutes let's somebody who's never
really exercised before if we can get
let's say just sarah walking five
minutes for five days in a row she's a
different person at that point and the
walking ten minutes or 30 minutes is
different on the map for her in other
words believe in baby steps and the more
baby steps we can get people to do the
more capable they will be of doing the
harder stuff don't start with the hard
stuff recipe for failure floss one tooth
some of you will be motivated some of
you won't be very motivated but I'm
hoping it's easy enough that you'll
actually do it now I've been there when
you're not flossing regularly you bleed
your fingers hurt there's all these D
motivators but the more you do it the
faster you get it doesn't hurt you don't
bleed after about four days in other
words the flossing all your teeth gets
easier and easier to do now a point I
want to make about habits here's where
they live and they live someone here and
here
habits do not live where it's hard to do
I can't think of any habit that is hard
to do
that is truly a habit so look and see
how people trigger these behaviors
Facebook is very good it's triggering
behavior mostly through email in one
case I got a notification that one of my
students had tagged me in a photo and I
was like okay I'll go check this out
actually I wasn't smiling I was like no
what could this be
if I go into Facebook and look around
and ice update my status and you know
this was when I was working in theory
and then I realized stupid Facebook I'm
supposed to be working I got triggered
so Facebook is very good at triggering
us to do what they want us to do which
is to go into their system and
contribute content make them a wealthier
company but when I looked at this from a
behavior design perspective for my lab
sterzick love it or hate it Facebook is
great at this very important these are
the most important nine words probably
that I've learned at Stanford put hot
triggers in the path of motivated people
a hot trigger isn't it doesn't mean it's
the the cool sexy thing the hot triggers
it says you can do this now you can
floss your tooth now the winning
ventures are great at doing this they're
great a hot triggering and more and more
of those triggers are coming through our
social network the peers that our
friends are triggering us not some big
company hot triggers don't aren't just
in technology they're all around us
they've been around for a long long time
notice how hot triggers work that's one
of the things I want you to do after
this talk and I think it's part of being
the genius in behavior change it's like
there's a hot trigger there's a hot
trigger there's a hot trigger we can use
in the system this is not a hot trigger
it's just a switch these are hot
triggers on the left is a cold trigger
because I can't drink milk when I see
that bus stop on the right I can because
I can buy it now the connection here is
this the notice how people use hot
triggers to then create habits so they
can remove the explicit trigger and the
behavior still happens you still log on
to Facebook every day used
we'll use a certain app and
what-have-you so these triggers need to
be in the path it needs to be with
something that people are already using
email Twitter on the outside of the
fridge on your bathroom mirror watch for
them and technology is great at
triggering behaviors and it's gonna get
better and better and mobile phones are
in some ways the holy grail last week I
ran a conference here at Stanford on a
mobile health we had 60 speakers who
talked about what what's working with
mobile and what's not I'm hoping you put
this hot trigger in your path it's an
important part I think of designing for
behavior change to experience it and
think about it so what I've tried to do
in this talk is have two types of
behavior habits reforming one and it
didn't happen because our phones didn't
ring very much is when a queue happens
you respond the phone rings I relax I
call that a queue habit the other type
of habit I call a cycle habit right
after I brush I floss every day at eight
o'clock I do this every time I go to the
gym I text my sister it happens on a
cycle those daily cycle habits are
bullseye of what we're doing right now
in my lab and it's what we care about
the most as you work on creating this
habit with floss one tooth I'm hoping
you will get a sense of how that works
how you respond how automatic it becomes
forget about a lot of what you've heard
common received wisdom about habit
formation I think a lot of it's wrong
and pay attention to your own processes
in creating habits I think there's still
a lot to be discovered there thanks
everybody